- me - why it's interesting yeah yeah so
I've spent a lot of time in Stockholm as
well you know I guess the way I think
about the world is if you lay out the
world in a flat map there are clearly
eight ten fifteen regions one could
argue that they want to put a flag if
they want to be global very simply
I couldn't imagine trying to achieve my
ambitions of building global brands
without having the presence in the
Nordics I think it's enough of its own
micro culture within a European
landscape that it's I first of all I've
and I've been to between Sweden Finland
I've I've been in the region nine ten
times already there's a comfort zone I
like the people I like the DNA of the I
like the blend of you know nobody first
of all I'm a hardcore hustler for
American so no part of the world is
gonna work as hard but but you know
there's some parts of Europe that don't
work at all by my standards I like the
work ethic innovation culture aspects of
the Nordic as a whole and so very simply
it is on the list of those ten regions
like South America like Asia like like
like Western Europe that I just know
that I will be yes and and just enough
business oriented the things I fear are
not you know Germany's a good example
it's a great amazing innovation but so
much infrastructure very difficult to do
business in you know especially things I
care about if you listen I don't know if
you heard my talk hire fast fire faster
right not very good in Germany when you
have six months when you're like so I'm
correct I'm aware so that's you know I
think remember I said self awareness I
know how I like running businesses so I
need to be careful where I set up shop
because for not only the people but what
are the government restrictions what's
the playing field but I
Fila Marik I feel a listen at the end of
day most of European rules are a little
bit more difficult for my fire fast hire
fast so that becomes an even playing
field the other thing that's gonna play
out for me is as my profile as a
businessman continues to grow there will
never we be places that the people that
I have more fans in more people
interested in me being and so one of the
reasons I come to something like this is
I want awareness in the marketplace and
now over the next six months I'll stay
I'll be very careful to watch my numbers
of consumption of my content in Finland
what kind of emails I get what kind of
business development things I get same
way I look at Sweden and Norway and
Poland correct and so you know as I was
saying to David before I'm like there's
not a lot of things that I do for kicks
and giggles I even though I'm a very
casual guy I've been very serious in
strategic about what I do in my life and
so I'm very optimistic
let me not listen I don't want to you
know listen as much as I'd like to paint
myself as a genius editor like you know
you got to eat dinner and I want to see
dick anything is that but but I'll say
this Gabriel even this interview why I
always say yes I'm a big believer in the
following statement people make the
world and for me I like people naturally
people like me naturally and and maybe
something you know my PR team is always
mad at me I'll do some little blog I'll
do an interview and then I'll say no to
CNN or Wall Street Journal and they're
always like no no you have to do better
time management and I don't think they
understand yes
more people will read about me in those
places but the depth of people you can
only do one on one one on two one on
four and so I'm always trying to put
myself in a position where I'm learning
it and meeting new people because you
know we may do something together 35
years from now who knows
I would take five to six people from the
New York office and bring them I have a
lot of young people who want to travel
the world very important to me to have
that culture I would then hire three or
four people from the market that knew of
me or vaynermedia so they really knew
what they were getting into we would
start with those seventy ten people we
would we would be very strategic about
having a client or two in the market you
know I met the head of marketing from
Finnair and I'm you know I said hey can
I have your card I mean I want to have a
client or two in the marketplace and
that and then we would set up shop and
then I would come over often and I would
try to do media and interviews to build
up the profile but at the end of the day
would be about the work
London is working I did a good job
promoting we got good people but the
only reason next year looks healthy is
the people that hired us are blown away
by the work they tell somebody else at
the end of the day no marketing no
charismatic leader Trump's being good at
your craft and so the number one thing
would be who are the 10 people a mix of
original Vayner employees and a mix of
the Swedes or the Finns or wherever it
is that could actually know what to do
in this market or in stockholm market
better than anybody that anybody else
could hire and we're obsessed with the
quality of the work you know the truth
is you'll I think you'll find this
interesting I'm not so compelled to say
they should hire me what what Swain
we're interesting for me is if they
believe in what I believe in they'll
naturally be interested in what I do
which is the world's changing I mean you
know I think people take things for
granted how are we recording this
interview you're doing it through your
telephone you know do you not crazy that
is if you talked about that 15 years ago
people don't understand how big this is
and so I think the thing that I would
say to conservative leaders and we have
them in the US as well is look if you're
not looking at how you're doing your
business every day and trying to say is
this smart for the world we live in
today because 2016 is already very
different to 2009 and it feels like
yesterday
and you have lead right I mean 2009 all
three of us will none of us here that
old I'm probably all this but 2009 feels
like I don't know yesterday seven years
ago you have leaders that are 50 60 70
years old in these companies and 1984
and 1975 feels like yesterday that's
right and so and go back 15 years and
nobody had a smartphone I mean you know
most of our communication in Sweden
Philip is through text and people didn't
text 15 years ago 20 years ago so I just
don't think people understand so I think
the number one thing I would say to the
conservative leadership is I'm a
businessman not a social media
enthusiast I think you need to look at
your profit and losses your P&L and you
need to think about what you're spending
money on and if you're not spending
enough money on things that are
happening in this device to drive your
business results that's something that
needs to be challenged I think as I said
in the room I think you spend the 20 to
50 hours as a leader to educate yourself
there's a site called Google and a site
called YouTube that you can type in
unbelievable amounts of words and they
will give you unbelievable free
information which then in my opinion
allows you to make a senior hire you
know what I'm worried about
I'm always worried that when I talk cuz
I'm motivational people get excited and
then I'm scared they're gonna hire
somebody to be their head of social
media but they themselves don't
understand it and that's a bad situation
so what I would say is educate yourself
know what this is then make a smart hire
because you know and then building a
department around it good and bad right
you got to put in the work if you own a
business or if you're the CEO of a big
business you've got to put in the 50
hours of reading and listening and
watching it's like anything else you had
to learn how to drive you how to learn
how to walk you have to put in the work
yes right and and it's a funny way of
saying you have to know how the world is
communicating you can't just show up and
not understand the shift and again like
I've been saying the biggest problem is
it's so big this is big what you and I
were lucky the three of us the last 60
years would have seen radio television
newspaper it was the same you have to go
back to ancestors that weren't aren't
alive anymore if you and I and Iraq and
everybody watching had our
great-great-great great-grandmother here
she would explain she would say yes then
they invented the radio and we used you
know or the telephone like this has
happened before there were people who
lived without a telephone they wrote
letters yes and when the telephone came
go read the articles
Western Union said that the telephone
was a fad and would be gone in three
years I know I know what you're
referring to
no I think it's the same there are
unbelievable amounts of politicians that
don't believe in this and then
occasionally you have some that do and
they're benefiting and it's not just
Donald Trump that people want to refer
to there are 25 year old 30 year old
mayors all across America that have won
because they went on Facebook and their
50-year old competitor tried to do
television and science it's happening
it's happening in all walks of life
nonprofits charity water pence was a
promise there were small charities now
they become big charities because
they're playing here and big charities
are playing the old world
as far as somebody doing good about it
you know I think the most interesting
stuff to me right now is media companies
that sell traditional media spending
money on this new media to drive their
business to sell old media think about
that you have television and newspaper
companies spending a lot of money on
social media to get people to read to
then sell companies to buy print and
commercials Oh hits stores you mean oh
by the way let's talk about that I
couldn't so bleared I almost brought
that up in the other room I think that
two of the best business deals that have
happened in the last ten years is the
person Jeff Bezos buying the Washington
Post and I don't remember who bought the
Boston Globe but it was an entrepreneur
very inexpensive here's why not because
I believe in the newspaper model but I
Lee believed that the brand is very
valuable
always but Brant the Boston Globe and
the Washington Post are brands
and for the 35 40 million if you make
that brick when he bought the Washington
Post a lot of people ask me why the
basis buy it I said if you open your
Kindle if he would have won the game
for example if Apple bought The Wall
Street Journal and every time you turned
on your phone Wall Street Journal would
be the front page of The Wall Street
Journal over there and you have to swipe
and start it would be the most important
media company in the world so it's when
you Marvel comic books as a comic book
company it was crap but the people that
bought it made movies and it went from
being bankrupt to being worth billions
IP
yeah I think Donald Trump has activated
social in a way that people didn't
understand and has benefited greatly and
I think that neither one of them are
doing a good job because they're both
really full of [ __ ] meaning they're the
best way to do social if you're a
politician is to prove that it's you
more both of them should be doing
unbelievable amounts of Facebook video
and of periscope and things of that
nature but they're behind the written
word
you can look I know when Donald's
tweeting as Donald and when it's his
team doing it Hillary is a machine it's
all not her and so I think the great
thing about social is that authenticity
and I think that as well as Donald's
doing if he or if she would to do a lot
more video for example I just gave this
talk I was looking at people saying nice
things I replied in video form that
person knows it's me they don't have to
guess if it's my intern if it's somebody
back in the States and that depth is a
connection and so I think the great
myths of politicians is not to use more
video and audio and that's why I would
say that they're not using it as well as
they could course and they want scale
yeah so you can get scale if your
interns are tweeting for you it's harder
for you to do it but I think when
Hillary's on the way to her next event
in the 10 minutes she's in the car
she should be videoing 10 people cuz it
scales Taylor Swift does this extremely
well as a pop star she does a lot of
engagement she shows up at people's
weddings it's not a good use of Taylor
Swift's time to show up to somebody's
wedding that they said Taylor can you
stop by my wedding but it is let me tell
you why when she goes even though
there's only 45 people at that wedding
or 100 people at that wedding or 200
people at that wedding
the media picks up on it and gives her
millions at scale and so what people are
misunderstanding is that when you do
authentic deep engagement the market
rewards you
for it and you actually get scale no no
no it's no different the question that
the guy asked in the other room he goes
well how do you become a thought leader
by being a thought leader you're right
it's it's hard it's hard to be authentic
so how do you be authentic by being
authentic you know listen I I always
used to say this it's like doing
push-ups you and I if we want muscles
you have to do the push-ups you can't
read about they're doing the push-ups
you can't outsource doing the push-ups
and so and so there's a reason that
people who are authentic and actually
doing are winning because everybody else
is trying to figure out the shortcut
because I believe technology is a
gateway drug to traditional I believe
what I do here allows me to get to the
moment where if you watched me all the
stuff he recorded all those handshakes
all those selfies it was all the work I
did here that got to the moment where I
got to shake his hand and take that
picture so I use technology to scale the
intimacy I think so
sure I mean look think about who you're
willing to do things for it starts with
your family and then it's your best
friends then it's your friends then it's
your acquaintances then it's strangers
I'm trying to close it hundred percent
by putting by putting in the work
absolutely and to me if you're really
smart the way I think of it and this is
very important I make the world smaller
for potential customers not customers
and that's a very important distinction
if you were to do things with the intent
to cash in on it you will lose because
the other person will taste it the
reason my stuff works is the same reason
when you ask me
why don't you tell me what to tell the
conservative business people why they
should hire you I don't want to I don't
like to sell I like to guilt and
leverage people into being interested I
am I I think the best sales people in
the world are the ones that don't sell
that are the ones that actually have
people coming to them to buy and there's
only one way to do that provide upfront
value with zero expectation in return on
a micro level on a macro level I expect
it turning out to being good correct
correct
so if I give you 50 interviews a
business advice a tip on a stock pick up
your daughter at a abandoned house in
New Jersey and I ask you for something
small and K years that was very rare I
have no idea but you know I'm trying to
go extreme if I do so much for you and I
asked for a little bit in return and you
say no I'm unfazed and I think most
people are faced most people give and do
expect something in return
I think the reason I'm winning is
because I don't I just don't I know it
works out but I'm empathetic to know
sometimes it doesn't sometimes people
want from you and don't want to give and
that's okay because you will win on a
macro level I genuinely believe that my
life is broken up into wine library
kicks me dividends each year because
it's still owned family business
speaking I do very well in that but the
far majority of my money is my salary
and the distribution of profits of
vaynermedia which is really what I do
for a living and then you know luckily
occasionally some of my companies that I
invest in sell or go public so I have
some big events right when Twitter went
public when Facebook went public when
buddy media was bought by Salesforce but
I'm also very investing in my world
meaning I can make a lot more money from
vaynermedia if I just stayed a 500
employees instead of 800 this year I
would have made a lot of money but I'm
reinvesting in myself
because your long-term I suppose you
mentioned a venture capital company on
top of that the medium yes that future
well venture is already happening what I
mentioned was private equity buying
brands it's very real it's the only
reason I build vaynermedia to build a
business that was client services would
have not been interesting to me they're
just not good businesses I think so I
think so it's why I built it no problem
yes and that's why I built it because
remember right now I'm still hungry and
on fire and I want to buy the New York
Jets
but I've hopefully another 60 years of
my life and here's what's gonna happen
in those 60 years my kids are gonna grow
up and have interests I'm gonna lose
family and friends to diseases something
will happen at a macro geopolitical
level that scares me and so not only do
I want a marketing machine to sell the
bubble gum brand that I buy and flip it
or to buy a an American football team
but if my mother dies from a rare
disease that's not been cured I'm gonna
want to use that machine to build
awareness and to find a cure if my
daughter becomes infatuated with
volcanoes I want to use that marketing
machine to give her the best position to
do what she wants in her life if my
grandson wants to do X Y & Z I want that
marketing machine to give him the best
chance to do that and so I think it's a
very important machine to have for the
rest of my life just the process of just
the process to buy them to me the
journey is way more interesting than the
finish line